[Music]
i'm coming
more than two years ago when we were
finishing last of us part two and we're
working on those flashbacks within that
scene for the first game we got excited
with the idea of like oh man what if we
made the last of us part one to look as
good if not better than what we have
done with us was part two which we
really pushed the boundaries of like
what we could do from
gameplay in a graphical standpoint and
felt like if we do that we could
actually come even closer to original
vision of what the first game would have
been had we not been constrained by
technology
the original
creative vision of the last of us i
think in a lot of ways was larger than
what the playstation 3 was capable of
the tech of the ps5 it's like an open
box of tools and goodies that we can
play from and draw from the 4k hdr
improved haptics 60 frames
help us to reimagine the last of us
[Music]
it gave us opportunities to rebuild our
characters at the highest fidelity
not only are the characters more
detailed i mean down to the the irises
and the pupil depth you know you fall
into the eyes of the characters
aside from that the facial animation is
just way more
believable like all the nuances all the
little subtle reactions glances glares
right like you get all of it
almost closer to sort of the original
performances
so no matter what you stick to me
light glue like glue light glue got it
good good we are able now to not only
just have the highest fidelity
characters in the cutscene
but also in gameplay it's the same
character so now we can do these
seamless transitions in and out
every part of the game has benefited
from seamless transitions and emotional
[Music]
pretty scripting huh
our stories happen in gameplay on a
stick you knew my mom
all this stuff is designed to keep you
constantly in this world
riley come here
now you got this go
one of the
things that the playstation 5 is really
enabling
is that we're able to have a density of
physics objects in a scene that would
just we could never do before like this
has always been
the dream is to have this number of
bumpables chippables breakables
destructible objects in a scene just
makes the world feel
rich makes you feel lived in
materials can have the properties that
you'd expect the turret truck in in
pittsburgh when it's firing at you and
it's just ripping apart the concrete and
sending objects flying left and right
seeing things break like there's fear
there's a real fear that it invokes
and it's giving us a much more dynamic
range of gameplay to play with
around him
our ai tech has just increased
incredibly what we were building the
basis off of was the last of us part
two's ai and it has sophisticated
systems for things like the fundamental
knowledge model of how these npcs
perceive and understand what the player
is is much more sophisticated
now how the enemies are communicating
with each other how they're chasing you
how they're flanking you how intense
that fight feels it's so much more
rewarding coming out of it from the
other side
one of the other big ai improvements is
the buddies
the buddies technology that we developed
for the last of us part two has this
very sophisticated understanding of like
okay this is where the enemies can see
their exposure we not only have exposure
we have future exposure so buddies can
know okay that enemy is walking forward
and they're about to round this corner
so in three seconds that corner is going
to be exposed so i'd better move now to
avoid this enemy seeing me this really
lets the buddies make very complex
decisions and maintain that that feeling
of stealth much more believably
another big enhancement to the gameplay
is that we have this technology called
motion matching
motion matching is this technology
that's basically using logic that tries
to match
the desired movement to a bucket of
hundreds of animations
a mocap doctor has gone in and
run this whole gauntlet of movements to
get a really full set of all the
different ways a person can move and
then it's basically every frame trying
to find the best matching animation that
fits the path of where the character is
going to go and this motion model just
gives this really seamless sense of
transition the player's movement is just
a lot cleaner this really smooth organic
movement through the space
first we just had to build that core
experience and then beyond that we
wanted to add several features that fans
have been asking for
for example we now have a permadeath
mode
along that we've added a brand new
speedrun mode so players can time
themselves there's a whole community of
gamers i just want to see how fast i get
played through this game
beyond that we added a bunch more of
unlockables so there's all these
different outfits for ellie and joel
that people can unlock
a model viewer mode so people can really
appreciate the details we added
award-winning accessibility features
every single accessibility option that
we offer that's a barrier removed for
someone
as she surveys the apartment her eyes
wander to joel she steps past the couch
he wears the wrist watch sarah gifted
him which now has a cracked face to my
knowledge this is the first playstation
game that has audio description built
into the game built into the cinematics
now it's night time joel stirs in his
sleep and that's really the way we've
tried to push the frontier of
accessibility on this game
[Music]
so much of the identity of the last of
us is the world
we revamped completely the art direction
you know everything from
these expansive vistas that not only are
they beautiful but you feel the
environment you feel the environments in
a much more visceral way the rooftops
overlooking the capital building for
example like just the breath of fresh
air when you go up there and you just
like you feel that
sort of release in intention
and then you know to juxtapose that down
in the tunnels in wilds and you get that
dank flooded tunnel feel that humidity
you can actually feel it all these
environments are just completely
reimagined
now we got our engine on the ps5 those
haptics the 3d audio they're fast
loading it really creates a much more
immersive and because of that much more
emotional experience one of the things i
absolutely love with the 3d audio and
the last of us part one is being able to
hear an enemy before they sneak up on
you
and trying to do a stalker fight with
the 3d audio is just so much fun
you're hearing them skitter around in a
different room and you're hearing them
trying to get it behind you
having that two-part reaction of like
hearing turning seeing reacting it's
just really heightens that sense of just
being grounded you are in this character
you are in this world
now
with the playstation 5 the amount of
control that developers have over the
dual sense it's really really cool all
the guns in the game have a variable
amount of resistance on the triggers
when you aim them the way it works with
the bow is that at the very beginning
when they're starting to draw the bow
there's a little bit of resistance and
then as the bow gets taller and taller
the amount of resistance is increasing
and then when you release the bow you're
also getting that resistance going out
of the trigger
when you are aiming and firing the
shotgun you're going to get a epic
vibration on the shot and then what i
think is one of the ways that the
dualsense really advances things is
you're going to get a hypothetic
vibration on the pump of the shotgun
and what's much more sophisticated about
that on the dual sense is that an effect
has a little like speaker in it
and it's playing an audio file that
comes through in the vibrations and
those two beats
as what you're going to feel on the
controller
this looks like a good spot
this also ties in to the new workbench
animations so if you're seeing joel
taking apart a gun or screwing something
in or putting a new stock on a gun that
moment where he's like jamming that on
you're gonna get that haptic feedback on
that
we have you know haptics all across the
board you know for all the moments you
kind of expect for clambering jumping
landing
mailing getting melee like all those
kind of high intensity moments we have
represented in the haptics
what i personally absolutely adore is
the way we can enhance the really like
quiet subtle moments of gameplay so it's
like when joel goes in to pet the
giraffe getting that little light touch
on the haptics as he's petting the
giraffe
to me that's the essence of the last of
us it's the high tension moments it's
the low tension moments it's all of it
feeling
grounded it's you're feeling immersed in
this world it's all about bringing you
along with that story in as many ways as
we can and that's what the new
technology on the playstation 5 is
allowing
[Music]
was that everything you hoped for
jury's still out
there's something special about that
core experience of playing as joe and
ellie on this journey
then to take that experience and really
honor it
and
keep the authenticity of it
but elevate it in every way possible
whether it's pipeline whether it's art
direction whether it's a technology
everything that allows us to make that
experience better
not different extremely better
that's why to me this is a definitive
way to play the last of us
you